I want to know this from you.
Doing a lot of movies, of course you have to
have your favorite, right?
Yeah. Who's the favorite person?
I guess you can say this, you've been able
to attach yourself to in comedy.
You shared the screen with.
Who's your favorite?
You can leave me out of it.
I don't want the pressure of you feeling
like you have to say me because I'm here.
I already know where you put me, so let's
not even do that.
Oh, good. All right. Because you're
number 15. You're probably the 15th best
person I've worked with.
And that's high because I've worked.
I've done a ton. Yeah.
I'll take it. I'm saying your top 15.
That's what I'm saying. You didn't have to
say it at all.
I mean, obviously.
Created a bond with John C Reilly.
Super fun.
Great guy.
So why can't you just say John C Reilly?
I did, didn't I?
You said. Obviously I created the bond, but
you didn't say John C Riley is my favorite.
I don't know if I. I mean, yes.
Are you stuttering? Because it's a simple
question.
John C Riley. Okay, but.
But I've enjoyed.
So you think John C Riley is better than me?
Oh, man, I'm not putting
you on the spot. By the way. By the way, I
don't even care.
I don't even care. I don't want you to think
I'm even into this because I'm not.
But if I was.
You think it's better to work with?
If so, why?
You told me it didn't matter.
It doesn't.
Forget it. Throw it out the window.
Throw it out the window. Close it.
Throw it out. I'm not saying.
He's better than you.
Yeah.
And by the way, if he was, that's fine.
Okay. No, I'm not saying that.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Because we all have our distinct abilities.
What we do better than other people.
Is that why you've never done another movie
with me?
Huh? Yes.
Wow.
That is it.
That. That's totally it.
No. You and John C Reilly are something
different.
It's. It's a comedy duo that the things that
the action that's happening, especially in
regards to comedy is obviously not written
but the comfort that you guys have in one
another and the trust that you guys have in
one another and the ability to.
Like exchange the levels, right?
When I look at you guys and stepbrothers and
I look at you guys in Talladega Nights, I'm
looking at two different performances, but
I'm also looking at changing of the guard in
both situations. Yeah, and there's scenes
where you guys are clearly giving the other.
Yeah, for sure of.
And that and that kind of common goal of, of.
You know, just. Playing it through the
character as opposed to.
Yeah. Not not keeping track of who's going
to do what.
Funnier. Yeah.
You just. You don't care, though.
You don't care. Just serving the story and
and but I was also going to say what's really
been enjoyable has been working with non
comedic actors who you find a way so like if
we're going to use stepbrothers as an
example.
Richard Jenkins like casting someone like
Richard Jenkins and getting this amazing
comedic performance.
Grounded.
Comedic performance. Exactly.
That's like it balances out what you're doing
and that's that's the beauty to what you do
well.